The joe rogan experience.
Speaking of,
I dunno what we're speaking of,
but we need to talk about Kanye just,
oh,
Jamie's got crazy.
Kanye conspiracy theories slash.
Theories.
Well,
first,
so first of all,
he's like,
he came out for trump recently.
He sort of,
he wore a make America great again hat
on,
but he also called trump a ball thief.
Why suddenly too?
He did.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah,
he called them balled crook or a
appalled named Connie is a lunatic.
Yeah.
So I could care less what he says about
him.
He loves saying,
Jamie Sleeps with a picture of Cognac.
Stop.
I don't believe that.
She didn't to believe that.
Yes.
Come on.
People believe everything you're saying
about me.
It's not a,
it's a pendant with a picture with his
picture in it.
Jamie's a big fan of two things.
Nuclear Weapons and trump.
He's,
yeah,
he loves nuclear bombs and he loves
physics class.
Yeah.
So trump before,
here's,
here's what,
here's what I like.
Well,
Connie is a lunatic,
but I do like candace owens who was also
new on the scene and my Fox News world.
You love that.
I love you love conservatives and
candace is just like,
she walked in from work the other day
and I was like started listening to Fox
News is on.
Of course I'm watching.
I'm like,
who the hell is this?
You Say Fox News is on of course,
because Fox News just blaring propaganda
through your house all the time.
Do you ever switch it up like have like
CNN on the back?
Nine Fox News on in the living room.
I watch it.
I do watch CNN.
Alex Jones says 200 1:30 PM to watch him
for wars.
Exclusive on Canyon.
Candice and Kanye exclusive.
I don't,
it doesn't happen every year.
It's like alive.
What does he get to say?
Featuring candice and Kanye,
so I need a lump them in together,
but he talking about them.
Everyone thought they were going to be
on this show together is exclusive.
He probably called them Kanye.
It's Alex Jones.
I could care less that Connie says.
I like what canvas says,
you chop one of my legs off and it's me
versus him to the battle of the death.
I'm still winning that fight 10 times,
10 times out of 10.
So you wish the fight kept going 100%
yeah.
It's a weird way to stop a fight too.
When a guy's not taking damage,
he's just got a leg that's not working
properly.
Well,
and the problem was too,
you know,
he almost,
he basically called timeout and asked
for the doctors to come in.
Once you've done that,
the fight's over,
I think.
I think the ref literally thought,
you know,
he should have just called the fight,
right?
He shake your leg was broken or
something.
Like what did it,
what was his thought process,
I guess?
And then,
and then the doctors came in and then
they started feeling around and they're
like,
you know,
they're like right here,
I think is Tibi is fractured.
It's,
I can feel the bone.
I'm like,
doc,
I promise you just get out of here.
Let me,
there's,
let me fight.
I got to car,
I got an ink,
uh,
a calf cramp or something.
I was like,
you don't just lying to them,
like,
just get out of here.
Let me,
let me go.
I promise it's fine.
I don't feel a thing.
It's not hurt.
I'm good.
Um,
and then they stopped the fight and they
pulled a stool to pull the stool from me
too.
So remember that.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
What was that about?
That was my commissioner that was,
that was New York Athletic Commission at
its best.
Like pull the stool and I fell in a,
and then a bunch of people were like,
hey man,
did they call the fight because they
hit,
they thought you couldn't stand.
And I said no,
I,
I hope not because that would have been
very unfortunate cause I fell on
national TV.
Got Charlie Brown tie all three stooges.
Molarity curly thanks for nothing doc.
Yeah.
Why did he pull a stool?
It was just a mistake.
I think I stood,
I think I stood up,
I was like,
hey,
maybe if I get the crowd into it,
maybe these guys would get out of here
and let the fight go.
So I like stood up and I was like,
let's go,
you know,
and I'm sitting on the stool and I
freaking looked at him and I was like,
you better hope they don't let me off
this toolbox.
I'm going to break your face,
you know?
And then I stand up and then he,
and then the guy pulls a stool.
And then second later I'm on my butt.
Exit.
Scammers run off with 660 million in ICO
earnings.
See,
this is like what you were saying about
the Nigerian people getting online and
them not knowing certain scams.
And then we get,
it's like scammers find a way in every
system.
There's not tons of scams out there.
They're just getting repurposed.
You know,
that just another trick,
they just put a little twist on it
changes the name and it's a new scam,
but it's all the same scams.
I show you my,
you wanted to know my postal scam
postal.
Yeah.
I've actually never done this.
But uh,
it's like where you to get arrested for
what you're about to say.
Well,
I don't know.
I just be careful.
Okay.
Well,
I've never done a pit is strong.
Those mother fuckers come down on you.
I've never done it,
but this is something that,
uh,
I think somebody told me they used to do
in college.
I don't know.
I don't even know if it really works,
but like I said,
like I wanted to send you a letter.
Uh,
I would put you as the,
uh,
yeah,
just switch return address and the
sender address.
Throw it in one of those blue mailboxes.
Hey,
they'll go,
hey,
no stamp returned to sender.
Now I sent you that letter.
Hmm.
Okay.
They'd probably know that one already.
Yeah,
they probably do you to do that with
like a letter of they'll probably,
yeah.
Yeah.
They're probably like,
what?
How'd it get all the way over here
in the center?
She's dropping off in California and so
we'll speed Ohio the fuck out of here.
They know better.
They know better today.
Yeah.
They're smarter than you,
Bro.
Famous con artists in history.
Right.
It was like this little tome.
It's smaller than like the smallest
paper back.
And it was the biography of this guy,
Victor Lustig was his name.
He was famous because he sold the Eiffel
Tower twice.
All right.
Uh,
and,
um,
he,
he had this,
uh,
this scam that he called,
I think it was called the,
the,
the Hungarian box.
Um,
I'll have to go back and look,
but basically what he would do is he
would get on a boat,
um,
in New York,
and he had this sort of beautiful
Mahogany box with a crank on it that had
two holes in it.
And he would show all the guests that he
would put a blank piece of paper and one
and turn a crank and a hundred dollar
bill would come out the other end.
Uh,
and he convinced them all that it was a
machine that made money and,
uh,
everybody would offer him an increasing
amount of money for this invention.
Uh,
and he wouldn't sell it until the last
day,
uh,
when he would sell it for,
you know,
40 or $50,000,
and then he would disappear and jump off
the boat and in France and never be seen
again.
People would tear it is,
yeah,
there it is.
What's it called?
Wow.
Yeah,
there it is.
Um,
but um,
but that's exactly what the mortgage,
let me see his face.
Look at that fucking creep
lugging them.
Wow.
Let me see that box again.
That is crazy.
So they,
yeah,
so it was obviously fake and,
and,
but that's what the mortgage scam was.
They,
they,
they were taking basically blank paper,
these,
these subprime loans that belonged to
janitors who we're gonna foreclose
within 10 minutes.
All right.
And they were telling people that,
oh,
we have this new mathematical process
that allows,
that actually makes this stuff really
safe.
Um,
and you can put it in your,
uh,
in your college endowment,
you can put in your pension fund.
And so all of these people,
you know,
who his retirement monies were based on
security is,
we're buying all this shit that they
thought was,
was aaa aerated.
And that's,
that's how they woke up and you know,
and in 2008,
2009 and they found their,
is where we're,
you know,
wiped out by 40% or whatever it,
it was.
I mean,
people are losing their minds right now
over the past 24 hours because of Iran.
Right.
And so what you're hearing is you're
hearing a lot of the,
um,
the,
uh,
the critics of the current president,
and apparently there are some that are
saying,
oh,
he's,
you know,
he's in,
she goes closer to a military conflict
with Iran.
Well these are the same brainiacs.
It said he was entering as closer to war
with North Korea and they,
everybody was completely wrong on that.
Uh,
I'm not saying that [inaudible] and the
others in the Iranian regime might not,
you know,
decide to become more bellicose.
But,
um,
I think they're,
I think they're looking at it wrong.
I mean there's this idea that,
um,
cause there's a couple of parts.
Part one is that they're saying,
oh,
look at what,
you know,
he doesn't have a plan b implying that
it's either this deal,
which even our European allies say is
inadequate.
Right?
Uh,
or it's a military conflict.
And that's kind of what the previous
president was,
was all about.
We either get this deal or we're having
a military conflict.
No,
there's other things in the works.
There's other options in that,
in that decision tree.
Um,
and so I think that's,
that's a false premise.
And the other thing when they talk about
it over the past 24 hours anyways,
is that,
well look at this.
This is gonna make it harder to get a
deal with,
with Kim Jong,
none from North Korea.
It's cause he's going to think that we
don't,
we don't support our deals.
Well,
I look at it a different way.
I think that Kim Jong Un is going to
look at this and think,
uh,
okay,
they're not going to put up with an
inadequate deal.
Right.
So he's gonna look at it and say,
well,
yeah,
that,
because nobody disagrees with the
Iranian deal.
They want to talk about.
They want to talk about how it looked.
The Iranians are complying with it.
Well,
the Iranians are complying with what
they agreed to allow him the deal,
right?
Which is none of their military sites,
the number of times inspectors who have
actually gotten on and inspected a
military site,
including Parchin,
the most important military facility in
Iran since that deal was signed in 2015
was zero.
Haven't been there because the Iranians
didn't agree to allow any of those sites
in this deal.
So that's like,
that's like saying,
that's like saying if you're a serial
killer,
you'll allow the police to come in and
search your home,
but you can't go in the basement.
Right.
Not that also he called was put their
bodies in the basement,
but I suspect that's the case.
So anyway,
that's,
it's an interesting thing and I,
I guess I wanted to throw that out there
right off the bat because I think Iran
right now is consuming so much of the
oxygen for people out there.
So people thinking that the reason why
we're backing out of the deals,
because the presence being unreasonable
home,
we're forcing what you're just saying.
It's a shit deal.
Period.
Yeah.
I think the idea that we have to stay in
it because it's better than the
alternative and the alternative,
you know,
being a war is not framing it properly.
I don't think that,
that doesn't make any sense to me,
but I think that the fact that the UK,
the,
the French,
the Germans have all agreed publicly
that it's an inadequate deal.
It needs to be fixed.
That tells you something,
but it also tells you that they have
real strong financial incentives for
continuing to do business in Iran.
They,
and as to Russia and China,
frankly,
the other signatories.